لقد بدأت إلى حد كبير في لعب لعبة الفيديو ،
انقر على محمل الجد ، وكما هو الحال في الدرجة ،
فقد حصلت على مثل الصف الخامس
والسادس ، ثم مثل الصف السابع ثم
الصف الثامن ، ومثل الصف التاسع ، صعدنا
إلى أعلى مباشرة وهذا عندما بدأت حياتي في
التدهور حقًا
لقد كان متصلاً بالإنترنت طوال الوقت في
كل لحظة من الاستيقاظ وكان يرفض
الذهاب إلى المدرسة ولن يأكل معنا
فقد فقد وزنه كان مستيقظًا طوال الليل
ومثل أي أم
أصبحت كيران بورتر قلقة بشكل متزايد
بشأن ابنها إيفان البالغ من العمر 16 عامًا
ولكن  لم تكن تعرف مدى خطورة
المشكلة ولكن يجب
تحديد نمط سلوكي محدد بوضوح شديد
الشدة في مثل هذه الطبيعة بحيث يكون
له الأسبقية للأنشطة الأخرى
التي كانت مهمة
لفرد في الماضي
كان إيفان لا شيء.  كان أكثر أهمية من
قدرته على الاتصال بالإنترنت واللعب على
فريق Fortress 2 Counter Strike
global Offensive الألعاب
المصممة لإبقائك تلعب لساعات أعتقد
أنها حقيقة  من المفيد أن نفهم أنه
بمجرد أن تستحوذ عملية الإدمان على
شخص ما ، فإنه يفقد
السيطرة على دافعهم للذهاب إلى الإنترنت واللعب
والقيام بأي شيء آخر يريدون القيام به على
الإنترنت يكون أقوى من أي شيء
يخبرون أنفسهم به أن عليهم
القيام
بهيلاري كاش  هو المؤسس المشارك لإعادة تشغيل
برنامج علاج للمرضى الداخليين
لمدمني ألعاب الفيديو ، فهو خارج
سياتل وبعيدًا قدر
الإمكان عن الشاشات الهادئة
ذات المناظر الخلابة والأهم من ذلك أنه لا يوجد
فرق كبير مثل النمو
من الشاشات إلى الشاشة طوال الليل
لا توجد شاشات
ما يحدث هنا عند بدء التشغيل ليس
مفاجئًا الكثير من وقت العلاج في الهواء
الطلق والتركيز على التفاعلات الشخصية ،
فنحن حيوانات اجتماعية ونحتاج في
الواقع إلى أن نكون حاضرين جسديًا
مع بعضنا البعض وجهًا لوجه حيث يمكننا
أن نرى ونسمع ونلمس  ويشتمون
بعضهم البعض ولكن هذه هي المشكلة ،
لا يزال العالم الحقيقي مليئًا بالمحفزات
لمدمني الألعاب المدمنين على الكحول
الذين تعلمون أنك لا تستطيعين ذلك  تناول الكحول مرة أخرى ، يمكن
لشخص مدمن على الكوكايين
أن يتناول الكوكايين مرة أخرى
مدمن التكنولوجيا ومدمن التكنولوجيا أعني أنه من
الصعب حقًا العيش بدون تكنولوجيا
[موسيقى]